لا تهداوا اصوات المدافع على جبهات القتال
في اوكرانيا على اطراف بلده كوبيانز شمال
شرقي البلاد يجهزه هؤلاء الجنود
الاوكرانيون انفسهم لاستهداف مواقع للجيش
الروسي باستخدام صواريخ جراند
نحن الان في موقف دفاعي هنا لا توجد اعمال
هجوميه من جانبنا والعدو يحاول اشغالنا
بالطائرات الانتحاريه لكننا سنواصل الدفاع
بهذا الاتجاه بعد ذلك يبدا التحضير
للاطلاق
يعلو صوت الصواريخ وهي تنطلق على اي اصوات
اخرى لا مجال للانتظار هنا كثيرا
لوجود مسيرات هجوميه روسيه في الاجواء
وتنطلق الاوكرانيه في محاوله اعتراضها
علينا الاخلاء سريعا فقد اصبح وجودنا هنا
غير
تغادر ايضا قاذفه الصواريخ على عجل قبل
اطلاق كامل حمولتها فالمكان اصبح هدفا
للقصف الروسي
قصف المكان الان
فقدت زميلي في الحرب هناك خسائر وهذا امر
مؤلم لقد ضحى هؤلاء بحياتهم من اجلنا لذلك
لن نخسر وسنقاتل هذا على الجبهه اما في
المدينه فيعبر الاوكرانيون عن امتنانهم
لجيش بلادهم لقد تركت الحرب اثارها هنا
كثيرون من سكان كوبيانس غادرها واخرون
يصرون على البقاء فيها رغم تعرضها للقصف
الروسي يوميا
استعاد الجيش الاوكراني
قبل عام من القوات الروسيه بعد ان تمكن من
السيطره على الاف الكيلومترات في مقاطعه
يواصل الجيش الاوكراني هجومه المضاد رغم
صعوبه التقدم وضراوه المعارك على جبهات
القتال ويقول انه لن يقبل باقل من تحقيق
النصر والعوده الى حدود البلاد المعترف
بها دوليا